bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
leur téléphone pour débattre de la
campagne à droite ce matin avec cette
photo rue de vaugirard les tout sourire
les six candidats à l'investiture et
l'air et l'annoncent de quatre débats
devant le combat est ce que la campagne
les républicains à commencer
véritablement je commence par vous il
nicolas
oui je pense que la campagne est en
route en tout cas si d'un ordre de
bataille qui se prépare
nous avons aujourd'hui donc un process
donc pour désigner le futur candidat
donc des républicains et donc des
candidats qui se sont ralliés à ce
procès est donc quoi qu'il arrive le 4
décembre nous aurons un candidat la
question qui peut se poser c'est de
savoir est ce que ça ne sera pas trop
tard aujourd'hui ce que j'observe c'est
que on parle de beaucoup de candidats
qui sont en campagne ou qui ne sont pas
déclarés et pour l'instant d'une
sûrement retard sur personne puisque
hormis marine le pen personne n'est
candidat officiellement déclaré on joue
sur les moins écoutés scanner georges
fenech d'ailleurs à ce propos entre les
membres à l'est républicain
je crois que les républicains cherchent
toujours elle cherche toujours un
candidat qui soit une alternative
possible mais le processus de
désignation est beaucoup trop long ils
doivent essayer de rattraper le retard
et ça va être compliqué mais l'élection
se jouera dans les dernières semaines à
la campagne ne commencera vraiment qu'en
février donc ce n'est pas trop tard
l'expérience nous a montré que tout
n'est pas encore joué on va en parler
les républicains qui sont peut-être un
petit peu en retard valentin blé lait à
eric zemmour lui est partout on l'a vu
est ce que c'est pas trop tôt pour le
coup
non c'est non je pense pas que ce soit
trop tôt
déjà pour l'instant ça a été précisé
eric zemmour n'est pas encore candidat
pour l'instant il fait dédicacer son
livre il fait la tournée des différentes
villes en france et
donc du coup ils présentent ils
présentent un peu ses idées ses constats
on a déjà entendu
quand il était sur six news et à la télé
et oui il est partout parce que a
aujourd'hui eric zemmour c'est un petit
peu la voix à droite qui portent parce
que c'est une droite de conviction
c'est pour l'instant le seul aussi qui
rectum du rpr les autres candidats
lâcher des leurs ne serait quand même
plus du rpr ne serait quand même plus la
droite traditionnelle la droite de
conviction la droite gaulliste et c'est
là dessus qu'ils regza moore capitalise
réponse il nicolas où vous vous en
pensez quoi
d'abord une la droite rpr pour moi qui
suis pourtant un ancien ça ne doit pas
dire grand chose aujourd'hui une
nouvelle génération
moi même je suis je n'ai jamais été issu
du rpr j'ai participé donc à l'ump j'en
ai même été à l'un des deux chocs
étaient à l'origine maintenant nous
sommes donc au sein des républicains la
question n'est pas là la question c'est
qu'est ce qu'on défend comme philosophie
quelles sont les propositions qu'on va
propres présenté aux français pour les
cinq ans qui viennent eric zemmour est
quelqu'un qui effectivement est brillant
intelligent quelqu'un qui sait débattre
qui fait un constat qui appuient sur des
points qui font mal et donc beaucoup de
français se reconnaissent là dedans mais
pour l'instant les réponses aux
questions les propositions pour réformer
la france on ne les connaît pas pas plus
d'ailleurs que chez les candidats
aujourd'hui qui s'affiche pour les
républicains mais ça c'est le moment de
la préparation de la campagne
aujourd'hui nous avons plusieurs
candidats à la candidature chez les
républicains ils seront désignés donc le
4 décembre mais nous sommes aujourd'hui
à six mois d'élections si on regarde les
scores qu'avaient les candidats y
compris à la dernière élection
présidentielle personne n'aurait misé un
kopeck sur l'élection d' emmanuel macron
au moins d'octobre 2010 9 donc nous nous
personnes nées en retard personne n'est
en avance comme il a été rappelé par
georges fenech l'élection elle va se
jouer en février donc aujourd'hui
certain son haut dans les sondages
certains sont bas mais ce n'est pas le
résultat de la présidentielle alors on
va écouter justement valérie pécresse
qui était en saône et loire vous parliez
de d'eric zemmour qui a une voix qui
porte on voit que valérie pécresse aussi
va avoir une voix qui porte regardez je
crois que le président macron a été
inspiré par machiavel vous le savez vous
connaissez cette fameuse phrase de
machiavel machiavel disait gouverner
c'est faire croire moi je crois que
gouverner c'est agir ou gouverner c'est
faire tout simplement il nicolas elle
n'y est pas allé de main morte c'est
quoi lasser blast emmanuel macron plus
que eric zemmour pour l'instant
il écope d'accord il est évident pardon
quand on est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle vous avez un sortant qui
s'appelle emmanuel macron bien sûr que
nous sommes là pour remplacer manuel
mâcon donc la cible principale reste
effectivement emmanuel macron d'autant
plus qu emmanuel macron a axé toute son
action politique pour dire en même temps
je suis de droite je suis de gauche sauf
qu'on se rend compte qu'il n'est ni l'un
ni l'autre il est effectivement ailleurs
et surtout très loin des préoccupations
des français prenez ce débat sur
l'augmentation aujourd'hui donc des
carburants les propositions nous les
attendons mais une fois de plus on
risque de sombrer dans des productions
qui ne vont concerner qu'une infime
minorité de français nous ce que nous
attendons ce sont des propositions qui
concerne tous les français alors on va
perdre et justement vous parlez diana
krall
la principale préoccupation qui reste le
pouvoir d'achat on l'a vu dans un
sondage hier eric zemmour lui pendant ce
temps là il était à milipol on va
regarder l'image un valentin embellie
d'ailleurs il a été critiqué eric
zemmour pour avoir
brandi un fusil d'assaut est-ce que
c'est pas un petit peu à côté d'eux des
préoccupations du moment valentin davis
ce déplacement à milipol
non je ne pense pas absolument pas parce
que la france a quand même vécu un
certain nombre d'événements qui sont des
attentats terroristes on en parle encore
on parle de ce qui s'est passé avec
samuel et pâtit également
assez dans la tête de tous les français
a encore dit un hommage a pas si
longtemps que ça
c'est un véritable c'est vraiment
anxieux pour les français les français
ont peur pour leur sécurité
et justement eric zemmour se déplacer
mon qui s'intéresse à tous les sujets
qui intéressent à la sécurité intérieure
à l'immigration aussi à la défense il
s'intéresse aussi à à l'économie
s'intéresse à l'éducation elle a
beaucoup parlé d'éducation récemment
beaucoup entendu parler de pouvoir
d'achat eric zemmour qu'en pense-t-il
alors après évidemment il ya énormément
de sujets qui touchent la france tu ça
va venir probablement petit à petit pour
l'instant il parle des sujets dont il a
envie de parler est la preuve que ce
sont les sujets des plus importants
actuellement puisque tout le monde part
de lui
alors effectivement tout part de lui on
a on a vu cet électorat et l'air très
courtisé par eric zemmour avant-hier
puisqu'il était à versailles c'est au
fief de françois xavier bellamy
opération séduction chez les catholiques
conservateurs de la manif pour tous les
l'ancien électorat fillonniste selon
eric zemmour il faut allier la
bourgeoisie patriotes qui est sûr
représentés dans l'assemblée au casse
populaire que qui elles sont absentes
écoutez le
il faut allier la sociologie de la manif
pour tous et la sociologie des gilet
jaune la manif pour tous en majorité
bourgeoise a échoué parce que les
classes populaires ils sont restés
étrangères il faut trouver les axes qui
rassemble ces deux sociologie le sujet
qui rassemble c'est la question au sens
large identitaire et de l'immigration
les autres combats ne sont pas moins
importants mais vont nous faire perdre
yves nicolin clairement eric moore
essaye de rallier ces déçus de la manif
pour tous
jeux surtout l'impression qu'ils aiment
ou il est dans la tactique il n'est pas
sûr qu est ce que je peux faire pour mon
pays pour effectivement préparer ce
dernier donc aux grands enjeux
internationaux et
nationaux donc maintenant il ya une
tactique de campagne qui effectivement
d'essayer de capter un électorat mais je
pense aujourd'hui que les français ne
sont pas de lui mais c'est un peu là la
tactique aussi d'avoir les voix pour
voter pour soi non mais avant d'avoir
des voix aux élections c'est au mois
d'avril avant d'aller chercher ces voix
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on connaisse le
corpus c'est à dire la volonté de chaque
candidat qu'est-ce qu'il veut pension
pays aujourd'hui nous avons encore plus
idéologique sheller qui très connus on
en parle depuis des décennies maintenant
nous attendons si la sensibilité de
chaque candidat sur des propositions
donc notamment sur la société mais
ramener effectivement la campagne
uniquement à la sécurité serait une
erreur on a effectivement des problèmes
de pouvoir d'achat on avait besoin de
sécurité ont des problèmes d'immigration
on est des problèmes de santé on a des
problèmes d'emploi aujourd'hui je vous
raconte juste un exemple en ce qui
concerne la ville mais nous avons sur
mon arrondissement six mille demandeurs
d'emploi or nous avons trois mille
offres d'emploi non pourvues quand que
fait-on pour faire en sorte que nous
ayons 3000 chômeurs de moins alors que
c'est possible parce que nous avons
trois mille offres d'emploi sur mon
territoire aujourd'hui nous avons un
vrai problème sur comment remettre
certains demandeurs d'emploi au travail
alors qu'il ya des offres de travail et
pas des offres factice de vraies offres
avec une bonne paye donc tu dire c'est
un vrai problème aujourd'hui nous avons
aussi donc des sujets de pouvoir d'achat
c'est évident et ça veut dire qu'il faut
travailler sur qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
redonner du pouvoir d'achat est-ce que
ça passe par une baisse de charges
sociales est ce que ça passe par des
chèques comme le propose le gouvernement
donc tout cela doit être dans le débat
de la présidentielle que donc de ne
parler que de quelques sujets qui certes
sont intéressants si elles sont des
préoccupations de certaines personnes
mais ne correspondent pas aux
aspirations tous valentin de l'ailier un
commentaire sur le ralliement des
classes bourgeoises avec avec les
classes populaires c'est la bonne
stratégie selon vous et ça empiète
évidemment sur l'électorat les
républicains
avant sa bonne stratégie puisque c'est
comme ça qu'elles gagnent et jacques
chirac c'est comme ça qu'elles gagnent
et nicolas sarkozy c'est à la fois à
l'alliance de la droite traditionnelle
de conviction et de les classes
populaires
oui c'est ce qu'il faut faire et j'y
vais il n'enquête pas sur sur
l'électorat et l'air puisque c'est
l'électorat elle est en fait eric
zemmour c'est la droite normal c'est la
droite traditionnelle c'est la droite on
la tendance à comparer l rapproché de
marine le pen à tort selon vous ah oui
non mais c'est c c'est tout à fait à
tort eric zemmour il n'a pas varié
il est toujours dans ses idées il assume
ce qu'il dit ils disent qu'ils pensent
et ça les français ils aiment ils aiment
ça ils en ont marre de voir
tout un tas de personnes voilà s'excuser
s'auto flageller
2d qui disent quelque chose qui va un
peu à l'encontre de la bien-pensance et
eric zemmour s'est totalement l'averse
il assume tout et il est de droite il
n'est pas de droite radicale ou je ne
sais quoi c'est encore une fois la
droite normal la droite traditionnelle
alors les selon les chiffres communiqués
justement par le party les républicains
les adhésions ont augmenté de 16 et demi
pour cent ces 20 derniers jours depuis
l'annnonce de de ce congrès le 4
décembre prochain qu'est-ce que ça
traduit selon vous yves nicolin les
personnes
s'inscrivent pour pouvoir aller voter
puisque je rappelle que le congrès est
ouvert aux seuls adhérents
bien sûr soul et moi je le vis est
également dans mon département jusqu'à
présent on était un peu dans le
brouillard en ce qui concerne la
présidentielle est ce que les
républicains allaient avoir un candidat
comment allait-il être désigné
aujourd'hui on sait que les républicains
vont avoir un candidat on sait la façon
dont ils vont être désignés d'opter les
français ont la feuille de route en ce
qui nous concerne et c'est ce qui fait
que beaucoup d'anciens militants dossier
adhérents ont décidé de repartir au
charbon de ré adhérer pour pouvoir
participer à ce processus nous ne sommes
pas pour un candidat autoproclamé on l'a
vu que ça n'a pas fonctionné avec vous
avez bien à l'écran les freins liés au
district
alors je sais pas si vous me parler mais
avant les six candidats à l'investiture
à l'écran voilà donc on a six candidats
donc effectivement vous en avait
quelques-uns qui semble être en
meilleure posture que le noir nous
verrons bien l'essentiel c'est que les
militants puissent s'exprimer choisir le
candidat qu'il souhaite voir arriver en
plus qu'à être sur la ligne de départ
d'un an de la présidentielle et après
tout le monde se mettra en ordre de
marche ce qui donnera une vraie
légitimité même si effectivement ce
n'est que la légitimité d'un parti
politique mais pas moins que lorsque en
marche va demain désigner son candidat
qui sera emmanuel macron pas moins que
lorsque monsieur mélenchon réunit sept
lots pour s'auto désigner lui-même donc
comme koné en présentiel ou pas moins
que les amis de derry zemmour on devait
lui apporter son soutien quand il
déclare à sa candidature donc nous
sommes dans un processus où sur la vème
république ce sont les partis politiques
qui effectivement concourent à
l'expression du suffrage universel et
qui vont me permettre de
d'identifier des candidats qui seront
ensuite proposés aux français alors
justement on connaît les mieux placés
valérie pécresse xavier bertrand et
michel barnier lui qui serait très
populaire auprès des jeunes et l'air
apparemment à 50 jours du congrès sa
stature internationale et sa loyauté
sans faille séduit cette grosse
fédération que représentent les jeunes
et leurs onze mille adhérents ont
regardé
le ministre des affaires étrangères
commissaire européen négociateur pour le
brésil aujourd'hui quand on le voit on
se dit oui cet homme peut-être sur le
perron de lisez les jeunes militants
sont très à cheval sur la question de la
fidélité au parti il travaille de
manière bénévole pour leur famille
politique se lève très tôt et se couche
très tard pour aller coller des affiches
pour aller distribuer des tracts michel
barnier incarne cette fidélité valentin
blé lait je vous pose à vous d'abord la
question parce que cette question la
fidélité on l'a entendu beaucoup chez
chez les jeunes qui soutiennent eric
zemmour c'est une des raison d'ailleurs
pour laquelle ils ont quitté souvent le
les républicains pour se tourner vers
eric zemmour le fait que xavier bertrand
ou valérie pécresse ont trahi et entre
guillemets le parti même si vous repris
leur carte l air depuis
moi je suis toujours républicain je suis
toujours dans le parti j'ai toujours ma
carte et or beaucoup de personnes qui
aujourd'hui soutient eric zemmour sont
toujours chez les républicains
effectivement vous avez montré tout à
l'heure les photos des candidats - dont
il manque des candidats ou et laurent
gautier ou souhaits du julien aubert ou
et moi une nouveauté you we eric zemmour
qui aurait pu être aussi candidat je
trouve que cette primaire c'est un peu
c'est la primaire de 2016 nour abbés on
va être moins de votants que pour la
primaire europe ecologie les verts
bon c'est pour créer une dynamique ça va
être compliqué vous parlez de de michel
barnier qui est fidèle à son parti c'est
très bien mais est-ce qu'il est fidèle à
ses convictions je suis pas sûr parce
qu'il était quand même encore il ya
quelques années pour une europe fédérale
aujourd'hui bon il a l'air de plutôt
prendre un tournant souverainiste si je
veux dire
on peut changer d'avis évidemment il n'y
a pas de problème moi je pense que les
l'air ont raté
la préparation de cette primaire ils ont
voulu faire une primaire ouverte la plus
ouverte possible au niveau des candidats
au niveau des des électeurs sur la cub
créé une dynamique là maintenant on a
rallié bertrand qui est bas dans les
sondages michel barnier qui en tout 10
inversement on à eric zemmour qui est le
seul candidat à droite qui peut se
qualifier au second tour être face à as
maintenant sinon ce sera marine le pen
si c'est pas zemmour ce sera marine le
pen c'est ça la réalité c'est que cette
primaire ne sert à rien en fait elle
sert juste à désigner soit le premier
ministre de d'emmanuel bâton soit ben je
sais pas ce qu'ils vont faire ensuite
parce que dit il faut savoir que sa
liaison en cause a été mis en place mais
bon je sais rien on enseigne a toutefois
évolué évidemment une élection est une
grande inconnue par définition je laisse
le mot de la fin nicolas puisqu'il nous
reste une minute pour réagir à est ce
que vous venez de dire
oui l'on mange d'abord je rappelle
simplement que cette élection elle n'est
pas fait encore nous avons encore six
mois et ceux qui sont aujourd'hui haut
dans les sondages seront peut-être on
peut être disparu donc quelques mois
aujourd'hui moi je moi je répète les
choses la primaire ouverte c'était la
grande arnaque du siècle on l'a vu moi
je l' ai vu dans ma ville où des gens de
gauche sont venus voter pour éliminer le
candidat de droite qui ne voulait pas et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
eu une primaire qui a été vraiment
complètement différente notamment sur le
plan des résultats on a bien vu que les
sondages là encore lui donner certains
regagnant la primaire n'ont pas été
vérifiés donc moi je dis à notre
adhérent donc les républicains prudence
c'est bien d'avoir effectivement donc
une conviction aujourd'hui ont des
racines vaudra demain il faut surtout
être prudent et se rappeler du processus
de désignation des candidats à
l'élection présidentielle ce n'est
jamais celui qu'on croit qu'ils étaient
lus ils sont par conséquent si la
réserve beaucoup de surprises et on
verra cela à l'issue donc des quatre
débats qui seront organisés le congrès
pour le 4 novembre et peut-être un débat
avec eric zemmour dans la foulée merci
beaucoup pour avoir participé à ce
départ en direct dans la matinale
berthet france